do you um
do you think there's other alien
civilizations out there first do you
think there's
other life out there first do you think
there's life in the solar system
second do you think there's life in the
galaxy and third do you think there's
intelligent life
in the solar system or the galaxy
outside of earth so intelligent life
i have no idea it seems deeply unlikely
possible but i'm not even sure if it's
plausible
so that's a special thing to you about
earth is somehow intelligent life came
yes and it's only you know very briefly
probably
extremely briefly uh oh you mean like
it's always going to be like we're going
to destroy ourselves exactly oh boy
and life will continue on earth happily
uh probably more happily
um so trees and the dolphins will be
here i'm telling you and the cockroaches
and the
incredible fungi you know they'll be
fine
uh so life on earth will be fine it was
fine before us
and will be fined after us so i'm not
that worried
about intelligence life but i think it
is unlikely even on earth
is unlikely out of what is it five
billion species across the history of
the earth yes
there's been one an intelligent one and
for a blink of an eye
uh possibly not much longer than that uh
so i
i wouldn't bet on that at all though i
would love it of course
you know i i wanted to
find aliens since i was a little girl
and so
of course i initially wanted to find
ones that i could be friends with
and i've had to let go of that dream
because it's so deeply implausible
but see the nice and sorry to interrupt
but the nice thing about intelligent
alien civilizations
they may have more biosignatures than
non-intelligent ones
so they might be easier to detect that
would be the hope
on earth that's not the case but it
could be the case elsewhere oh it's not
the case on earth
most of the biosignatures we have on
earth are created by quite simple life
if you don't count pollution pollution
is all well
so you don't see uh polluting gases
as a as a possible like i look for
polluting gases
i would love to find polluting gases
well you know
i'd be worried for them of course the
same way i
i think about my alien colleagues all
the time looking at us and i'm sure they
worry about our pollutions
but it would be a really good robust
unambiguous sign of life if we found
complex pollutants
so i look for those too i just don't
have any hope of finding them i think
intelligent life in the galaxy at the
same time that we're looking
is deeply implausible but life
i think is inevitable and if it is
inevitable
it is common so i think there will be
life
everywhere in the galaxy now how common
that life is
i think will depend a lot on whether
there's life in the solar system beyond
earth
so i'll adjust my expectations very much
based
on there being life in the solar system
if there's life
in the venusian clouds if there's life
in the if there are by singers coming
out of the plumes of enceladus if
there's life on titan
oh yeah that's right and yeah yeah
plumes of enceladus that's the um
that's the saturn one it's the moon that
has the geysers that come out
and so you can't see the under the
subterranean oceans but
it's supposed to it's so it would be in
the atmosphere i was going to ask you
about that one
uh have you looked at that uh have you
is is that a hope
for you to use the tools you're using
with
rascal uh and other
ways for detecting the 16 000 um
molecules that might be biosignatures to
look at enceladus
yes that's absolutely the plan is that
what's that what's the limiting factor
currently is it the the quality of the
telescopes is
what's what the the quality of the data
yeah the quality
of the data the observational data and
also the quality of
rascal and other associated things so
we're missing a lot of fundamental data
to interpret the data that we get and
we don't have good enough data but
hopefully we will
in the coming decades we'll get some
information on titan we have dragonfly
going over
we'll get the plumes of enceladus
we will look at the clouds of venus and
there's other places and so
if we find any life or any sign of life
ever like on mars then i'll adjust my
calculations
and i'll say life is not just inevitable
and common
but extremely common because all of
these places we've mentioned the
subterranean oceans on enceladus the
methane oceans of titan the clouds of
venus the acidic clouds of venus
these are places that are very different
from the places where we find life on
earth
even the most extreme places and so if
life can originate in all of these
completely different habitats then life
is
even more resourceful than we thought
yeah that's really
everywhere that's really exciting if
it's everywhere
if if there's life on just one one of
the moons
if it's on mars anywhere anywhere in the
solar system and i will
bet everything i own that every solar
system every planetary system
has a potential for habitability you
know because even if they don't have a
habitable planet they'll have moons
around other giant planets and
there'll be so much life so for me
that's
the only thing to figure out now whether
life is
inevitable and quite common throughout
the galaxy or
everywhere but it's somewhere between
those two
intelligent life i make no bets and if i
had to bet
i would be against yeah to me
like two discoveries in the 21st century
would change everything
one is and maybe i'm biased but
one is a discovery of life in the solar
system
i feel like that would change our whole
conception of
how unique we are in the universe i i
think i'm much more eager than you are
to jump
from basic life to intelligent life i
feel like if there's life
everywhere like the odds are
there has like we cannot like you
oh i see you're you're saying there
could have been many intelligent
civilizations out there
but they just keep dying out it's like
literally i was detecting them you know
ships in the night
ships in the night oh that's that's
ultra sad
just like is it sad a graveyard the
earth is not better for having us
is it we it doesn't owe us anything
would you be sad to find alien giraffes
would you be disappointed
if you found alien giraffes because i
would not no well giraffes
first of all they look goofy with their
necks and everything but no we do not
[ __ ] on giraffes
okay giraffes are wondrous animals are
deeply understudied we still know so
little about them because no one does
phds and giraffes
i am to this point i made phd in
phosphine when people aren't doing pgs
and giraffes we do not know enough about
giraffes
i think it was like ricky gervais that
did a whole like a long thing
but that's ricky gervais to talk about
giraffes that is not his expertise
yeah but it's a stupid next it doesn't
make any sense
i mean that's giraffe's a very
resourceful animals who do incredible
things
and can kick a lion why don't you climb
the tree why don't you climb the tree
you don't need to grow
through the the lengthy evolutionary
process [ __ ] on giraffes
i do okay giraffe animals i would very
appreciate that
i i take it back i apologize i i trust
i trust your expertise on this uh the
the the thing that makes humans really
fascinating and i think the earth i'm a
human
is where we create yeah
we create things that are yes there's
all the ugliness in the world
there's all the on the on the biological
and the chemical level there's the
pollution
but we create
beauty if you if you even from a physics
perspective look at symmetry
as somehow capturing beauty the breaking
of symmetries stuff grounded in all the
different definitions of symmetry
we're good at like creating things
so as fighters
but not giraffes okay but yes this is a
spider
yes there are spiders that crystals
bubbles of air so they can breathe
underwater they can literally scuba
dive there are spiders that can create
parachutes so they can glide
and talk about symmetry look what
spiders can do
and i just thought of spiders but if i
was an alien species
coming to earth there'll be plenty to
wander and we would just be
one one other thing yeah clunky
yeah naked monkey yeah the ants might be
even more fascinating
the ants ants can figure out exactly
through some emergent
consciousness what the maximum distance
between their
trash their babies and their food is
just from without any of them knowing
how to do this and collectively they've
learned how to do this
if i was an alien species i'll be
looking at that well so that was the
other thing i was going to mention the
second thing
is i tend to believe we can engineer
consciousness
but at the at the basic level understand
the source of consciousness
because if consciousness is unique to
humans
and if we can engineer it that gives me
hope that
it could be present elsewhere in the
universe that's the other thing that
makes
it's an open question that makes humans
perhaps special
is not maybe the presence of
consciousness but some kind
somehow a presence of like elevated
consciousness it does
again maybe human-centric but it feels
like we're more conscious than giraffes
for example in spiders
yes i won't deny that there is something
special about humans i
you know they're my favorite species
they are
they are you know some of my best
friends
are humans and i
i i think highly of humans it's it's
great
i just don't have great hope for
our longevity and specifically i don't
have great hope given that we're the
only species our five billion that did
this cool consciousness trick
i just i don't want to bet on finding um
a kinship elsewhere that's quite
interesting to think about
i don't think i've even considered that
possibility
that the that there would be life in the
solar system
so that indicates that very possibly
life is like literally everywhere
everywhere it can happen it does
yeah you know and like especially what
we're discovering with the exoplanets
now uh
they're how numerous they are or
earth-like
habitable quote-unquote planets there's
like they're everywhere the most common
type of planet yes
rocky it seems yeah so but i didn't
consider the possibility
that life is like literally everywhere
and yet
intelligent life is nowhere
long enough to uh to communicate with
each other to form little clusters
of um civilizations that expand beyond
the solar system and so on
man maybe becoming a multi-planetary
species is uh
is a less likely pursuit than um than we
imagined
but one of the things that makes humans
beautiful is we
hope but i i hope for
humanity and one of the things i hope
for
is that we become less obsessed with
conquering
and we become less obsessed with
spreading
ourselves i hope
that we transcend that that we're happy
with the universe without having to go
and take it
so you can hope for the species without
hoping for a multi-planetary existence
that is only i think the drive of
our most primitive instincts to go and
take
to go and plant a flag somewhere we love
planting a flag somewhere and maybe we
could overcome
that minor drive and once we do
the ai systems we build will destroy us
because we're too peaceful and they will
go and conquer and plant the flags
best of luck to them the cockroaches
will be happy to
um keep their keep to the business i
think they always have
i tend to believe that robots can have
the same
elegance and consciousness and
all the qualities of kindness and love
and hope and fear and that that humans
have
in principle they could yes i don't
really trust
the people who make them
this is about the giraffe comment isn't
it okay
i haven't forgiven you [ __ ] on
giraffes what have they done to you
you